Welcome to Speaking of Psychology, a biweekly podcast from the American Psychological Association. I'm your host, Caitlin Luna. Discipline in K-12 schools is not doled out equally, as black students, boys, and students with disabilities are suspended and expelled at much higher rates than other students. That's according to a report released last year by the government accountability office. These types of harsh discipline are even occurring in preschools across America. Any kind of punishment that takes a kid out of the classroom is known as exclusionary discipline, and it can have dire consequences on a child's future, including putting him or her at higher risk of falling into the school-to-prison pipeline. Also, looming around this issue is the fact that the Department of Education rolled-back protections intended to reduce these well-documented disparities in December 2018.
欢迎收听《心理学谈话》，这是美国心理学会推出的双周播客。我是主持人凯特琳·卢纳。K-12学校的纪律处分并不平等，黑人学生、男生以及残疾学生被停学和开除的比例远高于其他学生。这是政府问责局去年发布的一份报告得出的结论。这类严厉的纪律处分甚至在美国各地的幼儿园中也在发生。任何将孩子赶出教室的惩罚都被称为排斥性纪律，它可能对孩子的未来产生可怕的后果，包括使他们陷入“从学校到监狱”的管道风险增加。此外，笼罩在这个问题上的另一个事实是，教育部在2018年12月撤销了旨在减少这些有据可查的差异的保护措施。
To explain the current state of school discipline and what we can do to help children have a fair shot at an education, Our guests for this episode are Dr. Amanda Sullivan, Associate Professor of Educational Psychology at the University of Minnesota, and Dr. Ivory Toltsin, Professor of Education at Howard University. Both are experts on discipline disparities in pre-K through 12 schools. They presented at a congressional briefing hosted by APA on the topic in June 2019. Welcome, Dr. Sullivan and Dr. Toltsin. Thank you for having us. I'll start with you, Dr. Sullivan, first. You know, I gave a brief explanation of what the term exclusionary discipline means, but it would be helpful for you to expand on that a bit more for our listeners. Yeah, certainly. So common practices include suspension and expulsion, which generally bar students return to school for a specified time period. And this can be anywhere from days to the remainder of a school year. But it also includes things like early dismissals, so sending a child home with their parent off the record or extended timeouts in school suspension. So spending the day or
为了解释学校纪律的现状以及我们能做些什么来帮助孩子们获得公平的受教育机会，本期节目的嘉宾是明尼苏达大学教育心理学副教授阿曼达·沙利文博士，以及霍华德大学教育学教授艾沃里·托尔辛博士。他们都是学前班到12年级学校纪律差异方面的专家。2019年6月，他们在由美国心理学会主办的国会简报会上就此主题进行了发言。欢迎沙利文博士和托尔辛博士。谢谢你们邀请我们。沙利文博士，我先从您开始。您知道，我简要解释了“排斥性纪律”一词的含义，但如果您能为我们的听众更详细地展开说明一下，那将非常有帮助。好的，当然。常见的做法包括停学和开除，这通常会禁止学生在特定时间内返回学校。时间从几天到整个学年不等。但它也包括诸如提前放学，即在非正式记录的情况下让孩子随家长回家，或者在校内停学期间进行长时间的“暂停”。也就是在房间里待上一天或
several days in a room, kind of like what we almost think of as like study hall used to be. But it can also include things like using physical restraint, corporal punishment, and even involving law enforcement. And like you mentioned, taken together, it just shows this common feature of removing students from opportunities to learn. And it's important to be aware that it happens at all age and grade levels. So we see it used throughout elementary, middle, and secondary school, but also early childhood settings. So these practices get applied with preschoolers, toddlers, and even infants to a certain extent. Can you describe situations when this exclusionary discipline is used in schools? Yeah.
几天，有点像我们过去认为的自习室。但它也可能包括使用身体约束、体罚，甚至涉及执法部门。正如你所提到的，总的来说，这显示了剥夺学生学习机会这一共同特征。重要的是要意识到，这种情况发生在所有年龄和年级。我们看到它在小学、初中和高中，甚至幼儿教育环境中都在使用。因此，这些做法被应用于学龄前儿童、幼儿，甚至在一定程度上应用于婴儿。你能描述一下学校在什么情况下使用这种排斥性纪律吗？是的。
I mean, I think people have a misconception that it's reserved for very severe or dangerous behaviors, but we see it used for everything from tardiness to dress code violations, very kind of ambiguous or subjective offenses like disrespect or talking out of turn. And so it really gets applied across the boards as oftentimes a kind of go-to response to any behavior that's unwanted in the school setting. And these disparities show that this practice is overused in our schools in America today. Yeah, in many school systems, yes. And is it ever an effective way to manage disruptive students? I mean, or some people who might argue for it in certain cases. I think very rarely. I mean, I think the science of psychology has given us a lot of
我的意思是，我认为人们有一种误解，认为它只针对非常严重或危险的行为，但我们看到它被用于从迟到到违反着装规范等各种情况，以及诸如不尊重他人或插嘴等非常模糊或主观的违规行为。因此，它确实被广泛应用，通常作为对学校环境中任何不受欢迎的行为的一种首选反应。这些差异表明，这种做法在当今美国的学校中被过度使用了。是的，在许多学校系统中，确实如此。那么，这对于管理破坏性学生来说是一种有效的方法吗？我的意思是，或者有些人可能会在某些情况下支持它。我认为极少。我的意思是，我认为心理学科学已经给了我们很多
knowledge about how we respond effectively to both prevent inappropriate behaviors, but to foster positive behaviors. And in general, those are better options than any of these exclusionary discipline practices. I want to turn to that government accountability office report, which found that black students comprised 15% of all public school students. Yet they accounted for 39% of all students suspended from school during the 2013-2014 school year. That was the most recent data GAO had access to while doing its report. Do you believe that some of these, what are some the underlying factors that are causing this? Dr. Tolton. Well, I think the main factor is that not enough people care. These statistics have been out for so long now, decades even. It's consistent
关于我们如何有效应对以预防不当行为，并培养积极行为的知识。总的来说，这些选择比任何这些排斥性纪律做法都要好。我想谈谈政府问责局的那份报告，该报告发现黑人学生占所有公立学校学生的15%。然而，在2013-2014学年，他们占了所有被停学学生总数的39%。这是政府问责局在撰写报告时能获取到的最新数据。您认为导致这种情况的潜在因素有哪些？托尔辛博士。嗯，我认为主要因素是关心的人不够多。这些统计数据已经存在很长时间了，甚至几十年了。它在
across so many different data sets, so many different reports are finding the exact same thing. And there's just not enough people that care about the problem are who, who are, who, really believe that there are unfair reasons for this happening. There's too many people out there that think that black boys just do more bad things, and that's why they're being suspended more. But beyond that, some of the factors that's shown up in research, there's a cultural mismatch between a lot of black students and the teachers that serve them. And this isn't just based on race.
如此多不同的数据集和报告中都是一致的，它们都发现了完全相同的事情。只是没有足够多的人关心这个问题，或者真正相信这种情况的发生存在不公平的原因。外面有太多人认为黑人男孩只是做了更多坏事，这就是他们被停学更多的原因。但除此之外，研究中显示的一些因素是，许多黑人学生与为他们服务的教师之间存在文化错位。这不仅仅是基于种族。
is also based on socioeconomic status. A lot of children who come from poor communities, they're taught by people who don't understand them very well and who have certain stereotypes about their communities, how they grow up, their families. And these stereotypes manifest themselves in overly punitive disciplinary practices. It also leads to a lot of,
也基于社会经济地位。许多来自贫困社区的孩子，教他们的老师并不太了解他们，并且对他们的社区、他们的成长方式、他们的家庭持有某种刻板印象。这些刻板印象表现为过度惩罚性的纪律处分。这也导致了许多
educators believing that the children that they're teaching are threatening. And so whereas a white girl in a suburban school, her attitude may be described as sassy, a black boy in under-resourced school, that same disposition would be considered thuggish or, you know, those types of things. and that makes a difference on how people will view a problem. Another issue is one of the main factors that's associated with suspensions is academic disengagement. So students who seem to care less about their particular school are more likely to be suspended, and you're more likely to care less if you're going to a school where you're passing through mail detectors,
教育工作者认为他们所教的孩子具有威胁性。因此，当郊区学校的白人女孩的态度可能被描述为“活泼”时，在资源匮乏学校的黑人男孩，同样的性格会被认为是“暴徒”式的，或者诸如此类的评价。这会对人们如何看待问题产生影响。另一个问题是，与停学相关的主要因素之一是学业参与度低。因此，那些似乎不太关心自己学校的学生更有可能被停学，如果你去的一所学校需要通过金属探测器，
where you have this strict dress code policy, where you're not invited to express yourself as you go through this very important stage in your life. You're also not given a lot of agency into your own affairs, and you're not taught a curriculum that's culturally aligned to you. And so a lot of times these students will not engage as well, which leads to more punitive disciplinary policies.
如果你有严格的着装规范政策，如果你在人生这个非常重要的阶段不被鼓励表达自己，你更有可能不关心学校。你也没有被赋予对自己事务的自主权，也没有被教授与你文化相符的课程。因此，很多时候这些学生不会很好地参与，这导致了更具惩罚性的纪律政策。
So those are some of the underlying issues. Last point, black students are more likely to be suspended in predominantly black schools. When they go to integrated schools, they still get suspended proportionally more than the white students at those schools, but they get suspended less often than the black students at predominantly black schools. So this demonstrates that a lot of times it has something to do with the culture of the school. When you have a predominantly black student body, there's a certain attitude and mentality. There's something that the educators are seeing that they should not see that's leading to these harsh policies. You touched on a very important point about implicit bias and just a brief description is that's when we have attitudes toward people or associate stereotypes of them without being
所以这些是一些潜在的问题。最后一点，黑人学生在以黑人为主的学校里更容易被停学。当他们进入综合学校时，他们被停学的比例仍然比那些学校的白人学生高，但他们被停学的频率比在以黑人为主的学校里的黑人学生要低。这表明，很多时候这与学校的文化有关。当你有一个以黑人为主的学生群体时，有一种特定的态度和心态。教育工作者看到了一些他们不应该看到的东西，这导致了这些严厉的政策。你提到了关于隐性偏见的一个非常重要的点，简短的描述就是，当我们对人持有态度或将刻板印象与他们联系起来，而没有
consciously aware of it. So can you elaborate more about how implicit bias factors into some of these disparities? Sure. And implicit biases are biases that's beyond your conscious awareness. They typically manifest themselves in decisions that you make without really thinking about them. And it's important for me to point out that while implicit biases are rampant, and I think that all of us have implicit biases, I think that, the explicit biases, the things that a lot of these educators will actually admit to are actually just as severe or maybe even more. So when we hear educators talk about kids from that community, when they say all of them come from single parent households and that's why they act the way that they act. When they say that, you know, none of these children are reading them on grade levels.
意识到这一点时，就是隐性偏见。那么，你能详细说明隐性偏见是如何影响其中一些差异的吗？当然。隐性偏见是超出你意识范围的偏见。它们通常表现为你未经深思熟虑就做出的决定。对我来说，指出这一点很重要：虽然隐性偏见很普遍，而且我认为我们所有人都有隐性偏见，但我认为，显性偏见，即许多教育工作者实际上会承认的事情，实际上同样严重，甚至可能更严重。所以当我们听到教育工作者谈论来自那个社区的孩子时，当他们说“他们都来自单亲家庭，这就是他们行为方式的原因”时。当他们说，你知道，“这些孩子中没有一个达到年级阅读水平”。
So why would we have science at this school? Or why do we have, why would we even have calculus at this school? These are things I hear all the time. And I think until we deal, you know, I wish we had the luxury to just zero in on implicit biases. But a lot of this stuff is blatant, dare I say it, racism and racial explicit biases. And these explicit biases are, you said they're playing out in schools all across America today. Yeah. Can you elaborate more about why black boys would be more likely to be expelled from all black school or predominantly African American schools?
“所以我们为什么要在这所学校开设科学课？或者我们为什么要在这所学校开设微积分？”这些是我经常听到的事情。我认为在我们处理这些问题之前，你知道，我希望我们有奢侈的时间只关注隐性偏见。但很多东西是公然的，我敢说是种族主义和种族显性偏见。而这些显性偏见，正如你所说，正在当今美国各地的学校中上演。是的。你能详细说明为什么黑人男孩在全黑人学校或以非裔美国人为主的学校里更容易被开除吗？
Yeah. It has to do with the way that people see the school environment. A lot of times when we think about suspensions, we think about it as on an individual level. We don't think of it on a systemic level. And this makes us think that there's certain children that are more likely to be suspended. certain teachers who are more likely to give referrals or send children out of class. But really, it's a larger structure. And that's something that we have to understand.
是的。这与人们看待学校环境的方式有关。很多时候，当我们想到停学时，我们认为这是个人层面的。我们没有从系统层面去思考。这让我们认为有些孩子更容易被停学，有些老师更容易给出转介或把孩子赶出教室。但实际上，这是一个更大的结构。这是我们必须理解的。
Typically, when you have a diverse school environment or have, especially an environment that has a lot of affluent children, children with parents with means, the school will accommodate those students in ways that they won't accommodate poor students. and they also perceive their behaviors, or they perceive the overall school environment as an environment that is conducive to learning. A lot of times we have principals that are assigned to predominantly black school
通常，当你有一个多元化的学校环境，或者特别是一个有很多富裕孩子、有经济能力的父母的孩子环境时，学校会以他们不会迁就贫困学生的方式来迁就这些学生。他们也认为他们的行为，或者他们认为整体学校环境是一个有利于学习的环境。很多时候，我们有被分配到以黑人为主的学校的校长，
because of people that hired them believe that they're disciplined problems. You rarely see a principal coming to a predominantly white school just because of the, just because of, they are a good disciplinarian. They go there because they know how to make that connection between what they're learning in school and going to college and different things like that. So what we need to assert and demand is that predominantly black schools need the same type of resources, the same mentality, the same care that the predominantly white schools are having. And to assign
因为雇佣他们的人认为他们是纪律问题。你很少看到校长仅仅因为他们是好的纪律管理者而来到以白人为主的学校。他们去那里是因为他们知道如何将他们在学校学到的东西与上大学等事情联系起来。所以我们需要主张并要求的是，以黑人为主的学校需要与以白人为主的学校相同类型的资源、相同的心态、相同的关怀。而分配
a coach to be principal of a predominantly black school because they, tough talk and because they talk about putting students in line, that's, that demonstrates a bias in and of itself and it usually leads to these strict disciplinary policies that we see. Yeah, we also see that behaviors are treated very differently and perceived very differently. I mean, from an early childhood onwards. So we can look at like research that's used eye tracking shows that educators tend to spend more time watching the black students in a classroom. So they're looking for trouble.
一个教练去当以黑人为主的学校的校长，因为他们说话强硬，因为他们谈论让学生排队，这本身就证明了一种偏见，它通常会导致我们看到的这些严格的纪律政策。是的，我们也看到行为被对待的方式和被感知的方式非常不同。我的意思是，从幼儿期开始。所以我们可以看看像眼动追踪这样的研究，它显示教育工作者倾向于花更多时间观察教室里的黑人学生。所以他们在寻找麻烦。
And then when something does occur, it's perceived differently, like Dr. Tolson mentioned. And so there's more observation of these students, but then regardless of what they do, again, anything from disobedience or speaking out of turn, that kind of thing, the harsher discipline tends to get applied. So when we look at the research that has looked at like what happens to students when decisions are made, white students tend to be penalized. for much more severe behaviors, whereas students of color are more likely to be penalized for things that are very much judgment calls around what's acceptable. And oftentimes, things that are actually acceptable and adaptive in their communities are the things they're getting punished for in schools. And so I think a lot of things come back to misunderstandings of culture, misunderstandings of child development, behavior, learning, and mental health, that then we're
然后当事情发生时，它的感知方式是不同的，就像托尔辛博士提到的那样。因此，对这些学生的观察更多，但无论他们做什么，同样，从不服从或插嘴，诸如此类的事情，更严厉的纪律往往会被应用。所以当我们查看研究，观察当做出决定时学生会发生什么时，白人学生往往因为更严重的行为而受到惩罚，而有色人种学生更有可能因为那些在什么是可接受的问题上非常主观的事情而受到惩罚。很多时候，实际上在他们的社区中是可接受和适应性的事情，却是他们在学校里受到惩罚的事情。所以我认为很多事情归结为对文化、对儿童发展、行为、学习和心理健康的误解，然后我们
penalizing kids for the misunderstandings of the adults in the settings. So this is a broader cultural issue in terms of we're saying it's the culture of the school. It's the culture of the people who are at the school. Do you have examples off the top of your head of schools that are doing this well in terms of working to reduce these disparities? Anything come to mind? Well, I think schools where they're actually attending to it, so monitoring their data, not just by race, but gender, disability status, where they are investing. in staff training to develop non-biased attitudes to engage in non-discriminatory practices. We see some really nice successes with investments in positive school climate in developing student engagement in using school-wide positive behavioral interventions
因为环境中成年人的误解而惩罚孩子。所以这是一个更广泛的文化问题，就我们所说的学校文化而言。你脑子里有学校做得很好的例子吗，在努力减少这些差异方面？有什么想到的吗？嗯，我认为那些真正关注它的学校，即不仅按种族，而且按性别、残疾状况监测他们的数据，并在员工培训上进行投资，以培养无偏见的态度，参与非歧视性做法的学校。我们在投资于积极的学校氛围、发展学生参与度、使用全校范围的积极行为干预
and supports where the focus there is on teaching and reinforcing positive behaviors as opposed to just punishing and in particular sending kids out because of unwanted behaviors. So it all starts with teaching. We don't expect students to magically come to school knowing how to read, so why would we think that they would walk into a classroom
和支持方面看到了非常好的成功，其重点是教授和强化积极行为，而不是仅仅惩罚，特别是仅仅因为不受欢迎的行为而把孩子赶出去。所以这一切都始于教学。我们不指望学生神奇地来到学校就知道如何阅读，那么为什么我们会认为他们走进教室
magically knowing how a teacher wants them to behave? And I'll add that it's probably more common than a lot of people think to have a school that have disciplinary policies that are fair. And a lot of times it starts with the principal. Teachers do not have the authority to suspend students. It's the assistant principal typically that makes that decision. But the teachers are the ones sending the students out.
神奇地知道老师希望他们如何表现呢？我还要补充一点，拥有一所纪律政策公平的学校可能比许多人想象的要普遍得多。很多时候，这始于校长。教师没有停学学生的权力。通常是副校长做出那个决定。但教师是把学生赶出去的人。
But it's really the principle that sets the tone that the principal comes in day one and says, we're going to keep these students in our class. And these are the resources I'm giving you. This is what we're going to do. It typically happens. And, you know, there are programs out there restorative justice. And I think those programs work very well. But I think it's also a mistake that a lot of people make,
但真正定下基调的是校长，校长第一天进来就说，我们要把这些学生留在我们的班级里。这些是我给你们的资源。这就是我们要做的。它通常会发生。而且，你知道，外面有恢复性司法的项目。我认为这些项目运作得很好。但我认为这也是许多人犯的一个错误，
thinking that predominantly black schools need something differently than predominantly white schools. If you look at the way that they typically handle some of the same types of issues at predominantly white schools, if we just look at dress code policies, a lot of suburban predominantly white schools, their dress code policies are very loose, and they would never send us to the style.
认为以黑人为主的学校需要与以白人为主的学校不同的东西。如果你看看他们通常在以白人为主的学校处理某些相同类型问题的方式，如果我们只看着装规范政策，许多郊区以白人为主的学校，他们的着装规范政策非常宽松，他们永远不会因为着装规范而把
a child home over dress coats. But in a lot of the impoverished predominantly black areas, it's common. So just that alone will reduce suspensions. And we could just go down the list. Look at how you, you know, so my method, what I would tell people to do, what would you do if the student was white, honestly? And I think we could fix a lot of things just that way. Yeah, remember there was an issue a couple months ago of a school in Houston, I believe,
一个孩子送回家。但在许多贫困的以黑人为主的地区，这很常见。所以仅此一点就会减少停学。我们可以列举下去。看看你是如何，你知道，所以我的方法，我会告诉人们怎么做，如果你是白人学生，你会怎么做，老实说？我认为我们可以通过这种方式解决很多问题。是的，记得几个月前休斯顿有一所学校的问题，我相信，
where there was a dress code for parents and that created a lot of controversy because parents were, you know, dropping their children off, maybe they'd just gotten up in the morning or something and the issue was that the principal did not want parents to come to school and I guess, you may call pajamas or relaxed clothing, that sort of thing.
那里有一个针对家长的着装规范，这引起了很多争议，因为家长们，你知道，送他们的孩子去学校，也许他们早上刚起床什么的，问题是校长不希望家长来学校，我想，你可能会说穿睡衣或休闲服装，诸如此类的事情。
So what kind of message would something even like that send? And I'll be remiss if I didn't say that, that was a black principal. It was a predominantly, predominantly students of color, black and Hispanic. And they have a fair number of black teachers and a good number of black people who supported that decision.
那么，即使是这样的事情会传达什么样的信息呢？如果我不说，我会感到失职，那是一位黑人校长。那是一所主要是，主要是少数族裔学生，黑人和西班牙裔。他们有相当多的黑人教师和相当多的支持这一决定的黑人。
And it goes to show that even black people can be biased against other black people, particularly poor people. And I think that this idea that certain children come from certain neighborhoods that have these corrupted cultural values. And somehow they need to be put in line in order for them to achieve.
这表明即使是黑人也可能对其他黑人有偏见，特别是贫困人口。我认为这种认为某些孩子来自某些有腐败文化价值观的社区的想法。不知何故，他们需要被排好队才能取得成就。
So, you know, if you're in a predominantly white neighborhood, you know, gentrifying neighborhood and your parents are coming with flip-flops and they didn't dry their hair so as wet hair, that's fine. But if you have a black woman that comes in rollers, somehow they're extending this way beyond just a woman bringing her child to school and wanting her curls to be fresher when she gets to work, then when she drops the kids off. So there's this larger mentality that we have and it's not just racist class that we really need to check. I think it's just an extension of this notion of like respectability politics and schools.
所以，你知道，如果你在一个以白人为主的社区，你知道，正在绅士化的社区，你的父母穿着人字拖，他们没有吹干头发，所以头发是湿的，那没关系。但如果你有一个黑人妇女戴着卷发器进来，不知何故，他们把这延伸到了仅仅是一个女人带孩子去学校，并希望她在上班时卷发更清新，而不是当她送孩子去学校时。所以我们有这种更大的心态，这不仅仅是种族主义阶级，我们真的需要检查。我认为这只是学校里这种“尊重政治”概念的延伸。
And so it's not just schools trying to control and shape the behaviors of kids, but then we see it extending to the parents as well. I want to turn over to boys because in the report they were particularly overrepresented among students who received corporal punishment, physical punishment, by about 27 percentage points. And when I read the statistic, I was quite surprised because I thought corporal punishment was a thing of the past. So how are schools able to administer physical punishment and in what types of schools is this happening in and where are they around the country? I mean, it's still legal in, I want to say, about 19 or 20 states. So they're not violating any laws if they use corporal punishment. It's allowed, I am fairly certain it's more common in the South, which is true for a lot of the more severe exclusionary discipline practices. We tend to see higher levels in that part of the country.
所以这不仅仅是学校试图控制和塑造孩子的行为，而且我们看到它也延伸到了家长身上。我想转向男生，因为在报告中，他们特别在接受体罚、身体惩罚的学生中比例过高，高出约27个百分点。当我读到这个统计数据时，我非常惊讶，因为我以为体罚已经是过去式了。那么学校是如何能够实施身体惩罚的，这种情况发生在什么类型的学校，它们在全国什么地方？我的意思是，它在我想说的大约19或20个州仍然是合法的。所以如果他们使用体罚，他们没有违反任何法律。这是允许的，我相当肯定它在南方更常见，这对于许多更严厉的排斥性纪律做法来说也是如此。我们倾向于在该国那部分地区看到更高的水平。
But in a lot of ways, it's an extension of the same way we see differences regionally and certain groups around, acceptance of corporal punishment at home, that permissiveness extends into the schools again. And so it's not uncommon to see not just acceptance, but preference for that kind of response to misbehaviors in school settings. But again, it's legal in many states today, right now. Yes, I found that to be quite shocking that that was even a thing people were doing in schools. Do you have anything to add, Dr. Toltson? No, and it's not common. It's far more common to bring police officers in the school and arrest students for very innocuous behaviors. And that's much more of an imminent threat to us. But there are these pockets out there. There are, you know, as Dr. Sullivan said, there's probably about 19 states. And they're all listed online. They're pretty easy to find with a Google search. A lot of the states where it's, you know, there's probably about 19 states. And they're all listed online. They're pretty easy to find with a Google search. A lot of the states where, it's legal, they still don't implement it.
但在很多方面，这是我们看到区域差异和某些群体周围对家庭体罚的接受程度的相同方式的延伸，这种宽容再次延伸到了学校。所以，在学校环境中看到不仅接受，而且偏好那种对不当行为的反应并不罕见。但同样，它在今天许多州是合法的，就在现在。是的，我发现这非常令人震惊，这甚至是人们在学校里做的事情。你有什么要补充的吗，托尔辛博士？不，这并不常见。把警察带进学校并因非常无害的行为逮捕学生要普遍得多。这对我们来说是更迫在眉睫的威胁。但外面确实有这些小群体。有，你知道，正如沙利文博士所说，大约有19个州。它们都在网上列出。通过谷歌搜索很容易找到。许多州，你知道，大约有19个州。它们都在网上列出。通过谷歌搜索很容易找到。许多州，
And a lot of times you still have to have parents' permission to do it. But as with all of the different types of exclusionary are highly overly punitive policies, we see disproportionality when it comes to black students, in particular black male students. Can you touch on the arrest in school you just mentioned? What are we seeing, you know, bringing police officers to the school to remove students or if there's an in-the-school security officer that, involved with removing a student from the classroom. What kind of rates are we seeing this happening in? Very high. And, you know, these are some of the things that a lot of people probably don't, don't,
它是合法的，但他们仍然不实施。很多时候你仍然需要家长的许可才能这样做。但正如所有不同类型的排斥性或高度过度惩罚性政策一样，当涉及到黑人学生，特别是黑人男学生时，我们看到了不成比例。你能谈谈你刚才提到的学校逮捕吗？我们看到了什么，你知道，把警察带到学校去带走学生，或者如果有学校保安参与把学生从教室里带走。我们看到这种情况发生的比例是多少？非常高。而且，你知道，这些是许多人可能没有，没有，
weren't aware of. But most school resource officers are academy trained police officers with arresting authority. And they have no further training to, to, to work in schools than anybody out there chasing people who shoplift or who mug somebody. A lot of times these school resource officers are assigned there because there's no other good fit for them. So they're not people who just say, I love children and I want to work around kids. These are people who, for whatever reason, usually pretty nebulous reasons, are assigned to the school.
没有意识到的事情。但大多数学校资源官员是受过学院培训的警察，拥有逮捕权。他们没有比外面任何追捕偷窃或抢劫的人更多的在学校工作的培训。很多时候，这些学校资源官员被分配到那里是因为没有其他适合他们的地方。所以他们不是那些只说“我爱孩子，我想在孩子身边工作”的人。这些人，由于某种原因，通常是非常模糊的原因，被分配到学校。
another thing is that a lot of them are armed. Correctional officers in the prison don't carry guns, and they're not academy trained. They're trained specifically to work with that population. The police officers in school are armed, and they can make arrest. And then you have these laws. You have these school conduct laws, like what happened in South Carolina, where the officer body slammed the young girl. and it was called on camera.
另一件事是他们中的许多人携带武器。监狱里的惩教人员不携带枪支，他们没有受过学院培训。他们受过专门培训来与那个人群一起工作。学校里的警察携带武器，他们可以进行逮捕。然后你有这些法律。你有这些学校行为法，就像南卡罗来纳州发生的那样，警察把那个年轻女孩摔倒在地。而且它被摄像机拍到了。
But in South Carolina, there is a law that makes discipline problematic behavior in school. And they actually use the word obnoxiously in the law. So someone who's acting obnoxiously in the school is subject to arrest. So that makes things that you can do outside of school. You know, so the same black girl could go to a store. and catch an attitude with a clerk. And that would not be an arrestable offense, but you do it in school,
但在南卡罗来纳州，有一项法律使学校里有纪律问题的行为变得有问题。他们实际上在法律中使用了“令人讨厌地”这个词。所以一个在学校里表现得令人讨厌的人会被逮捕。所以这使得你在校外可以做的事情。你知道，同样的黑人女孩可以去商店，
and all of a sudden you have an officer body slamming you, are just arresting you. So we've really gotten far away from where we need to go. And the irony is a lot of these laws originate from a lot of mass shootings at school, which are more often, at predominantly white schools, but yet the laws end up morphing and end up disproportionately affecting black students, even though the behaviors of black students wasn't necessarily the original
对店员发脾气。那不会是可逮捕的罪行，但你在学校里这样做，突然间你有一个警察把你摔倒在地，或者只是逮捕你。所以我们真的离我们需要去的地方很远了。讽刺的是，许多这些法律源于学校的许多大规模枪击事件，这些事件更多地发生在以白人为主的学校，但法律最终发生了变化，最终不成比例地影响了黑人学生，尽管黑人学生的行为并不一定是法律的最初
impedist to the law. So it's a lot of things we need to think about when it comes to the way that we're using school resource officers right now. My personal opinion is that we need to do away with school resource officers altogether. That may be a radical thing for some people to hear, but if you're going to have a school security officer, they need to be trained to work in a school. And across the nation, you have people who have no training to work in schools.
诱因。所以当我们谈到我们现在使用学校资源官员的方式时，有很多事情我们需要考虑。我个人的观点是，我们需要完全废除学校资源官员。这对某些人来说可能是一个激进的说法，但如果你要有一个学校保安，他们需要接受在学校工作的培训。而在全国范围内，你有根本没有在学校工作培训的人。
I went to one school, the school resource officers, they had their mellow detector set up. I asked for the principal by name, and the school resource officers did not know the principal's name. Wow. And this was in Brooklyn, New York. And even some of the language use, too, like you described the word obnoxiously. I mean, that leaves a lot to interpretation of what that behavior means.
我去过一所学校，学校资源官员，他们设置了金属探测器。我按名字询问校长，学校资源官员不知道校长的名字。哇。这还是在纽约布鲁克林。甚至一些语言的使用也是如此，就像你描述“令人讨厌地”这个词一样。我的意思是，这留下了很多对那种行为意味着什么的解释空间。
It's not very specific. So it leaves a lot of room for a student to get removed from the classroom by a resource officer or calling the police. I want to turn out to students with disabilities who are also disproportionately affected, as they represent about 12% of all public school students in account for 25% or more of students referred to law enforcement. that includes being arrested for a school-related incident or suspended from school. So what do you think are some of the underlying causes of disparities for students with disabilities? Well, I think, again, there's these broad misunderstandings of development, behavior, mental health, and also just the nature of disability.
它不是很具体。所以它留下了很大的空间，让学生被资源官员带出教室或报警。我想转向同样受到不成比例影响的残疾学生，因为他们约占所有公立学校学生的12%，却占被移交执法部门学生总数的25%或更多。这包括因学校相关事件被逮捕或被学校停学。那么你认为残疾学生差异的一些潜在原因是什么？嗯，我认为，同样，对发展、行为、心理健康以及残疾本身的本质存在广泛的误解。
And then when we pair that with insufficient use of effective, what we know are highly effective approaches to behavior management, to classroom instruction, to delivering interventions to support their behavioral, and social emotional development relative to those disabilities, I think it's a recipe for disaster, and that's why we see that students with disabilities across the board, but particularly students
然后当我们把它与对行为管理、课堂教学、提供干预措施以支持他们相对于这些残疾的行为和社会情感发展的有效方法（我们知道这些方法是非常有效的）的不足使用结合起来时，我认为这是一个灾难的根源，这就是为什么我们看到残疾学生在各个方面，特别是
with learning and emotional disabilities, are very likely to be subject to these consequences, even though they're not going to help them improve their behavior, and even though in a lot of ways, much of what happens is counter to the spirit of the law and the legal protections put in place to prevent their exclusion from schools. But this notion of sending kids out is so deep,
有学习和情绪障碍的学生，非常容易受到这些后果的影响，即使它们不会帮助他们改善行为，即使在很多方面，所发生的大部分事情都违背了法律的精神和为防止他们被学校排斥而制定的法律保护。但这种把孩子赶出去的概念是如此根深蒂固，
deeply ingrained in how we think about responding to unwanted behaviors. Just the way you think about parents when a child does something wrong at home. It's pretty, we think of like the classic, like, go to your room, right? And so it remains the go to for a lot of kids, but even though when we know, when we have kids who are acting out because of their disability, for instance, if we have a child who's dysregulated, who has a severe emotional or behavioral disorder, who has a severe learning disorder that affects their ability to engage with a classroom instruction, Instead of thinking about the ways to tailor what's happening in the classroom, to support their learning, and to support positive behavior, exclusion can be the fallback a lot of the time.
深深植根于我们对如何应对不受欢迎的行为的思考方式中。就像你想到父母在孩子在家里做错事时的想法一样。这很，我们想到经典的，比如，“回你的房间去”，对吧？所以它仍然是许多孩子的首选，但即使当我们知道，当我们有孩子因为他们的残疾而表现出来时，例如，如果我们有一个失调的孩子，有一个严重的情绪或行为障碍，有一个影响他们参与课堂教学能力的严重学习障碍，而不是考虑调整课堂上发生的事情的方法，以支持他们的学习，并支持积极行为，排斥在很多时候可能是退路。
And you're talking more about students that with learning disabilities are emotional difficulties. Do students with disabilities like physical disability or being deaf or blind or something, do they fall into this category? Not the physical disabilities so much, but we also see it with students with developmental disabilities. So we have folks with fairly substantial language impairments, cognitive impairments, who are also treated in a way that's just inappropriate. And this report from the Government Accountability Office found that black students, boys and students at disabilities were disciplined at high rates, no matter what type of school they attended. So that was public schools, magnet schools, charter schools, alternative schools, or special education.
你谈论的更多是患有学习障碍或情绪困难的学生。患有身体残疾或失明或失聪等残疾的学生，他们属于这一类吗？身体残疾的情况不多，但我们也看到发育障碍的学生有这种情况。所以我们有相当严重的语言障碍、认知障碍的人，他们也被以一种不恰当的方式对待。这份来自政府问责局的报告发现，黑人学生、男生和残疾学生无论上什么类型的学校，受到纪律处分的比例都很高。所以那是公立学校、磁石学校、特许学校、替代学校或特殊教育。
So what does this tell us? I mean, I think it comes back to the insufficiency of the practices used and the insufficiency of the policies and procedures in place. support students. Just because students are going to a charter school, a private school, an alternative school doesn't mean that they're going to be implementing research-based practices, even though we know a lot about how to support behavior and behavior of students with disabilities in particular really well. Yeah. And I think it's also important to, you know, differentiate those categories a bit because black, in proportion to the students who are at that school, black students, black male students consistently are suspended more, but they're not suspended more at, say, a traditional school than an alternative school.
那么这告诉我们什么？我的意思是，我认为这归结为所使用做法的不足以及所采取的政策和程序的不足。支持学生。仅仅因为学生去特许学校、私立学校、替代学校并不意味着他们会实施基于研究的做法，尽管我们知道很多关于如何支持行为，特别是残疾学生的行为非常好。是的。而且我认为也很重要，你知道，稍微区分一下这些类别，因为黑人，相对于那所学校的学生比例，黑人学生、黑人男学生一直被停学更多，但他们并没有在，比如说，传统学校比替代学校被停学更多。
Most alternative schools have very, very high rates of suspension. But it's important to really get into the nuance of it. I remember having a conversation with an assistant principal at a mixed school. and I looked up his school stats and, you know, this is someone who I knew well enough to do that, but I looked up his school stats at the Civil Rights Data Collection and found that his school had disproportionality. And that's right there, you know, why do you think they have this disproportionality? And his explanation was that it was a suburban school that was attracting a lot of people from the city.
大多数替代学校的停学率非常非常高。但重要的是要真正深入了解其中的细微差别。我记得与一所混合学校的副校长进行过交谈。我查了他的学校统计数据，你知道，这是一个我足够了解的人，可以这样做，但我查了他在民权数据收集处的学校统计数据，发现他的学校存在不成比例。就在那里，你知道，你为什么认为他们有这种不成比例？他的解释是，这是一所郊区学校，吸引了许多来自城市的人。
It was in suburban Philadelphia. And a lot of parents were taking their students from the Philadelphia schools, sending them to this school, thinking that they would get a better education. And probably in a lot of regards, they are. But his theory, our hypothesis, was that these students were bringing some of the behaviors that they had in their inner city schools to that school, and that school just wasn't tolerating it. So we got into a larger, you know, deeper discussion about, you know, these are students who have been uprooted by their parents, who are in an environment that's much different from the one that they had, who are, you know, maybe was in a predominantly black school.
它在费城郊区。许多家长把他们的学生从费城学校带走，送到这所学校，认为他们会得到更好的教育。而且可能在很多方面，他们确实得到了。但他的理论，我们的假设是，这些学生把他们在内城学校的一些行为带到了那所学校，而那所学校只是无法容忍。所以我们进行了更广泛、更深入的讨论，你知道，这些是被父母连根拔起的学生，他们处于一个与他们以前的环境大不相同的环境中，他们是，你知道，也许是在一所以黑人为主的学校。
And all of a sudden, they're a minority in the school. They probably have teachers and other students who are looking at them certain types of way because they're from a different social economic. status. So of course you're going to see some adjustment difficulties and trying to deal with that strictly by suspensions is just not, you know, that's only going to further the rut that they're in. And he seemed to get that. But I think it's important that people know that a lot of these suspensions happen and the people who are doing them, they can offer you some pretty reasonable explanations. And we all have to think a little bit deeper and get a little bit deeper to the issue beyond the surface in order to really come up with long-term solutions.
突然之间，他们成了学校里的少数群体。他们可能有老师和其他学生因为他们来自不同的社会经济地位而以某种方式看着他们。所以当然你会看到一些适应困难，试图通过停学来严格处理这个问题只会，你知道，那只会加剧他们所处的困境。他似乎明白了这一点。但我认为人们知道很多这些停学发生是很重要的，而做这些事情的人，他们可以为你提供一些相当合理的解释。我们所有人都必须思考得更深一点，深入到表面之下的问题，才能真正提出长期的解决方案。
So a lot of this relates to just making these judgments and bringing, like you said, the explicit and implicit bias in the equation and really examining that. Did the principal have a response to that? Have you brought these important points to his attention? He said that he would try to do something about it. And he said that he would bring some speakers in. and I didn't follow up. This was a very personal conversation,
所以这很多与做出这些判断有关，并像你所说的那样，把显性和隐性偏见带入等式，并真正审视它。校长对那个有回应吗？你把这些重要的点引起他的注意了吗？他说他会尝试做点什么。他说他会请一些演讲者来。我没有跟进。这是一次非常私人的谈话，
but he did seem to understand what I was getting at. But, you know, I've never had any principle that had this type of disproportionality that wasn't able to give me a reason. So they all have their own explanations, but when you get deeper into the issue, And if you could just get them to care, if you can get them to see this, you know, this isn't right, you know, and these suspensions are not going to do the work for us, then, you know, they can do something about it. I think a lot of times the blame is placed on the students or their families without acknowledging that administrators, teachers have an important part in playing and the behaviors that occur in school.
但他似乎明白我的意思。但是，你知道，我从来没有遇到过任何有这种不成比例的校长不能给我一个理由。所以他们都有自己的解释，但当你深入到这个问题时，如果你能让他们关心，如果你能让他们看到这个，你知道，这不对，你知道，这些停学不会为我们做工作，那么，你知道，他们可以做点什么。我认为很多时候责任被归咎于学生或他们的家庭，而没有承认行政人员、教师在学校发生的行为中扮演着重要角色。
So we know enough from behaviorism from learning research about how to cultivate. certain behaviors, positive or negative. And so I think if we can kind of shift the way that school leaders and teachers are envisioning their role in this, and in this particular situation, I think asking why we don't explicitly teach, or at the very least articulate what the behavioral expectations are, and then support the behaviors that we want,
所以我们从行为主义、学习研究中知道足够多关于如何培养某些行为，积极或消极。所以我认为如果我们能稍微改变学校领导和教师在这种情况下的角色设想，在这种特定情况下，我认为问问为什么我们不明确教授，或者至少阐明行为期望是什么，然后支持我们想要的行为，
as opposed to just punishing the behaviors that we don't want, especially because we know there's enough research to show that that's not effective in cultivating change in the long run. So sending a kid home doesn't, it does not improve behavior. It's the main go-to in a lot of places, but it doesn't actually change anything. And it seems like you're mentioning a lot of important psychological concepts and psychological research that can be brought into these schools to help deal with this issue of exclusionary discipline in the fallout. Yeah, I mean, if we just trained all administrators and teachers and special educators on effective behavior management, on principles
而不是仅仅惩罚我们不想要的那些行为，尤其是因为我们知道有足够的研究表明，从长远来看，这种做法在培养改变方面并不有效。所以让孩子回家并不能改善行为。这是许多地方的主要首选手段，但它实际上并没有改变任何事情。而且你似乎提到了许多重要的心理学概念和心理学研究，这些可以被引入学校，以帮助处理排斥性纪律及其后果的问题。是的，我的意思是，如果我们只是培训所有的行政人员、教师和特殊教育工作者进行有效的行为管理，以及学习原则
of learning, principles of behavior, I wonder how much different things would look. Do you have a quick example of that, that you may say you're talking about cultivating positive behaviors. Can you have something you can share? Well, I just think about, so I have a four-year-old, and I engage with her differently, say, than some of her friend's parents do, for instance. And I know, because I'm a psychologist and trained in school psychology in particular, I know that if I spent literally 15 to 30 seconds before we go into a new situation explaining to her what I expect her to do in the next few minutes, like if we're going to go into this setting or just when we get home, I expect you to do X, Y, Z.
和行为原则，我想知道情况会有多大的不同。你有没有这方面的简短例子，比如你提到的培养积极行为？你能分享一些吗？嗯，我只是想到，我有一个四岁的孩子，我与她互动的方式，比如，就和她一些朋友的父母不同。我知道，因为我是一名心理学家，特别是受过学校心理学培训，我知道如果我在进入新环境之前花上15到30秒向她解释我希望她在接下来的几分钟内做什么，比如我们要进入这个环境，或者只是当我们回家时，我希望你做某某事，
that it's more likely to happen than if I just walk in and then get mad when she doesn't do the thing that I told her not to do. That same principle applies whether we're talking about four-year-olds or 14-year-olds or adults. I can do the same thing with family members who are adults or friends, right? If we make explicit what our expectations are, we're more likely to see the behaviors that we want. And that's not, I mean, that's just basic behaviorism. Do you think there is the issue is surrounding support in schools? I know we talked about a lot of these decisions to take students out of the classroom are with administrators. Do teachers who you've spoken with in these areas, do they feel overwhelmed?
这比我直接走进去，然后在她没有做我告诉她不要做的事情时生气，更有可能实现。同样的原则适用于我们是在谈论四岁、十四岁的孩子还是成年人。我可以对作为成年人的家庭成员或朋友做同样的事情，对吧？如果我们明确我们的期望，我们就更有可能看到我们想要的那些行为。这并不是，我的意思是，这只是基本的行为主义。你认为问题在于学校的支持吗？我知道我们谈到很多将学生带出教室的决定都是由行政人员做出的。你交谈过的这些地区的教师，他们是否感到不知所措？
Do they feel like they don't know what to do in terms of like they might have a student who's being disrupted for whatever reason? They have 25 other students they need to educate and just not having those tools to address it in a better way? Yeah. And I empathize with those teachers because a lot of these schools that have the highest rates of suspensions, they have. teachers on average that have the lowest number of years in the teaching profession. They have mostly junior level teachers. A lot of them have teachers who are in certain transitions and they for whatever reason take off a lot of time and so they end up teaching with substitutes a lot of times. And a lot of these schools
他们是否觉得在面对一个因为某种原因而扰乱课堂的学生时，他们不知道该怎么办？他们还有25个其他学生需要教育，却只是没有那些工具来以更好的方式解决问题？是的。我同情那些老师，因为很多悬学率最高的学校，平均而言，教师在教学行业的工作年限最短。他们大多是初级教师。他们中很多人有处于某种过渡期的教师，由于某种原因，他们请了很多假，所以他们很多时候最终是由代课老师来教的。而这些学校中的许多
have very low resources and so you know just the staff to do effective interventions is just not there. And so in a lot of these environments, it is, it becomes, you know, pretty enticing to say, I'm just going to remove a child that's given me problems, just to get through the day. They'll be quite honest. And then you slap on certain mandates that a lot of schools have that teachers have to improve test performance. And so you're getting all this slack about having students to meet certain benchmarks. And yet you have a student in your class that's just not getting it and don't really seem interested and seems to want to do anything except the work. And you know that when they take that test, that one student is going to bring down the entire average of the
资源非常匮乏，所以你知道，仅仅是进行有效干预的人员根本不存在。因此，在许多这样的环境中，说“我只是要移除一个给我制造问题的孩子，好让我度过这一天”，这变得相当诱人。说实话。然后你再加上许多学校都有的某些强制要求，即教师必须提高考试成绩。所以你得到了所有关于让学生达到某些基准的压力。然而，你的班上有一个学生就是学不会，看起来也不感兴趣，而且似乎除了学习什么都想做。而且你知道，当他们参加那次考试时，那个学生会拉低整个班级的平均分。
the class. It becomes, you know, very, you know, enticing just to say, you know, I want to suspend, I want to counsel the student out of my class because now they're messing up with my future. And all of this, I believe, could be dealt with on the policy level. I think that if we had better policies, and if we were able to distribute the resource to the school more equitably. A lot of times they have lower, lower quality teachers are lesser experienced teachers in these schools because they pay less. And so because of the way the, you know, a lot of the, the schools are funded through property tax, you have some schools in the fluent districts, public schools that can afford to pay their teachers, 10, sometimes $20,000 more than the
这变得，你知道，非常，你知道，仅仅说“我想停学，我想劝退这个学生离开我的班级”是很诱人的，因为现在他们正在搞砸我的未来。所有这一切，我相信，都可以在政策层面得到解决。我认为，如果我们有更好的政策，如果我们能够更公平地分配学校资源。很多时候，这些学校的教师素质较低或经验较少，因为他们支付的薪水较低。而且由于学校通过房产税获得资金的方式，你会在富裕地区拥有一些公立学校，它们有能力支付给教师比在资源匮乏地区教书的教师多10到20万美元的薪水。
teacher that's teaching in, uh, under resource district. Uh, so all of these things come together to create a, uh, a type of perfect storm, uh, for teachers to be more, more punitive. And again, the teachers aren't suspending. They're just sending them out of their classes. But then you have, um, you know, these, you know, principals and administrators, uh, that will conspire with the teachers and go on to have these students out of the class. And teachers aren't prepared necessarily to deal with the diversity of behaviors that students engage in in classrooms. I think teacher prep, if we look at it, it's disproportionately focused on the academic side. Even though we've known from research for longer than I've been alive, that effective behavior management is a gateway to being able to have the time and space to engage in effective instruction.
所以所有这些事情汇集在一起，为教师变得更加惩罚性创造了一种“完美风暴”。再说一次，老师们并没有停学。他们只是把学生赶出教室。但随后你有了，嗯，你知道，这些，你知道，校长和行政人员，会与老师串通，继续让这些学生离开课堂。而且老师们并不一定准备好应对学生在课堂上表现出的多样化行为。我认为教师准备，如果我们审视它，它不成比例地集中在学术方面。尽管我们从比我出生更早的研究中就知道，有效的行为管理是能够有时间和空间进行有效教学的门户。
yet we don't see that understanding necessarily reflected in teacher preparation or the standards and policies that are applied there. And so I would actually be curious to see how many teachers have more than a chapter or part of a day in their teacher preparation programs around behavior management, around disability, any of that. And the research is there. So when we ask teachers about their comfort level in differentiating instruction in managing behaviors effectively, many if not most teachers feel underprepared. And so we see it then in how they respond to student behaviors. And so more so than not, I think a lot of teachers rely on what they see from their supervising teachers or what they experienced in their practica or their student teaching experiences.
然而，我们并没有看到这种理解必然反映在教师准备工作或那里应用的准则和政策中。所以我实际上很好奇，想看看有多少教师在他们的教师准备项目中，关于行为管理、关于残疾等方面的学习超过了一章或一天的一部分。而研究就在那里。所以当我们问教师关于他们在差异化教学和有效管理行为方面的舒适度时，许多甚至大多数教师感到准备不足。所以我们随后在他们对学生行为的反应中看到了这一点。因此，我认为很多教师更多地依赖于他们从指导教师那里看到的，或者他们在实习或学生教学经历中所经历的。
And so if they were with a supervising teacher who had really good behavior management skills, who knew how to create a positive climate in their classroom and how to work with a variety of different students, then they can replicate that in their own practice. But if they had a supervising teacher who didn't have those skills, they're going to replicate what they saw. And if they didn't see something that worked out well, we can see that kind of the ramifications for the entirety of their careers, unless there's some intensive, effective professional learning after the fact. But a lot of professional learning that happens is kind of a one-stop kind of like a data dump. So that one-hour, one-day training, even though we know from research the type of training that actually is going to change teacher behavior. and be sustainable, takes coaching and takes kind of that long-term follow-up to really change the behaviors.
所以如果他们和一位有很好行为管理技能的指导教师在一起，知道如何在课堂上创造积极氛围以及如何与各种不同的学生一起工作，那么他们就可以在自己的实践中复制这一点。但如果他们有一位没有这些技能的指导教师，他们就会复制他们所看到的。如果他们没有看到行之有效的方法，我们就能看到这对其整个职业生涯的影响，除非事后进行了一些深入、有效的专业学习。但很多发生的专业学习是一种“一站式”的数据倾倒。所以那一个小时、一天的培训，尽管我们从研究中知道，真正能改变教师行为并具有可持续性的培训，需要辅导和那种长期的后续行动来真正改变行为。
But a lot of it's just not happening in-service training or pre-service training, for that matter. And before we get into more of like the what people can take away from this, I want to touch on a statistic I mentioned, the very top when I was introducing you both, is about preschools, which I found to be one of the more shocking statistics when I was researching this topic. So this is also happening in preschools where preschools are getting suspended and the numbers are much higher for black children and boys. APA's Health Disparities Office reported that preschool suspensions and expulsions dwarf those during grades K through 12 by more than three to one. So what's going on? Well, there are some districts that have made the policy to not suspend preschoolers.
但很多并没有在在职培训或职前培训中发生。在我们进入人们可以从中获得什么之前，我想谈谈我在介绍你们两位时在最开始提到的一个统计数据，是关于学前班的，这在我研究这个话题时发现是最令人震惊的统计数据之一。所以这也发生在学前班，学前班的孩子被停学，而且黑人儿童和男孩的数字要高得多。美国心理学会健康差异办公室报告称，学前班的停学和开除人数是K-12年级的3倍多。那么发生了什么？嗯，有些学区已经制定了不让学前班学生停学的政策。
And I support that policy. I think that that is one of those things where you should be able to say, you know, just cut and dry, you know, do not suspend them. And if it's a child that has, you know, certain developmental disorders and they need a special type of learning environment, then you can deal with that. But to just suspend preschoolers, I think it's something that needs to be done away with. Now, the reason why, and I think, you know, this is all speculation at this point, but it appear, and I'm going to speak as a preschool parent also. It seems as though standards and the things that we believe certain preschoolers are that preschoolers generally should be able to do by certain ages is out of whack with reality right now. The things that people are saying about what they need to learn, what they need to master before they reach the age of five, it doesn't comport with research. And, you know, the most rapid period of brain development is between the ages of birth and five.
我支持那个政策。我认为这是你应该能够说，你知道，干脆利落，你知道，不要让他们停学。如果是一个有，你知道，某些发育障碍的孩子，他们需要一种特殊的学习环境，那么你可以处理这个问题。但仅仅让学前班学生停学，我认为这是需要废除的事情。现在，原因，而且我认为，你知道，这一点目前都是推测，但似乎，我也将以学前班家长的身份发言。似乎我们认为某些学前班学生在特定年龄通常应该能够做到的标准和事情，与现在的现实不符。人们所说的关于他们在五岁之前需要学习什么、需要掌握什么的事情，与研究不符。而且，你知道，大脑发育最迅速的时期是在出生到五岁之间。
And students are catching on to different things at all different paces, you know, during that period. You know, you can easily have a class where, in preschool, where you have one student that's reading at a third grade level in preschool, and you have someone else that don't know their phonics yet. And quite possibly, by the time they turn seven years old, it's still possible for them to be at the same level, given what we know about brain development. But it doesn't really seem like schools are really get that. And preschoolers, they want to have fun, they want to play, they don't want structure and order.
而且学生在那段时期以各种不同的速度领悟不同的东西。你知道，你很容易在学前班有一个班级，其中有一个学生在学前班读三年级水平，而另一些人还不知道他们的自然拼读法。而且很有可能，到他们七岁时，考虑到我们对大脑发育的了解，他们仍然可能处于同一水平。但学校似乎并不真正理解这一点。而且学前班的孩子，他们想玩得开心，他们想玩耍，他们不想要结构和秩序。
And I've seen some schools that will try to make their preschoolers line up all the time. And, you know, they're giving preschoolers homework. Like, I've actually seen this. And these are schools that, that, that, try to create this rigorous learning environment, and they're really responding to this hyper-testing that we're doing. And they've really bought them to the philosophy that if you drill things as early as four years old, that you put them in a better position to pass test.
我见过一些学校会试图让他们的学前班学生一直排队。而且，你知道，他们给学前班学生布置家庭作业。就像，我真的见过这个。这些学校试图创造这种严格的学习环境，他们确实是在回应我们正在进行的这种过度测试。而且他们真的相信了这种哲学，即如果你在四岁时就开始灌输东西，你就能让他们处于更好的位置来通过考试。
And that's just not the way that preschool... meant to be. I don't think that's a developmentally appropriate way to run a preschool program. But I think that there is a connection between that and the suspensions that we see. I think we just see large-scale misunderstanding of child development. And so, I mean, I think, again, with my own child, like, we just had some kindergarten testing going on. And I didn't realize, but when we showed up, they wanted us literally, they wanted me to just leave her at the door and that she was supposed to be fine with being in a strange situation with adults she'd never seen. And they notated and they told me this that she had difficulty separating.
那根本不是学前班应该有的样子。我不认为那是运行学前班课程的发展适宜方式。但我认为这与我们看到的停学之间存在联系。我认为我们只是看到了对儿童发展的广泛误解。所以，我的意思是，我认为，再次以我自己的孩子为例，我们刚刚进行了一些幼儿园测试。我没有意识到，但当我们出现时，他们实际上想要我们，他们想要我只是把她留在门口，而她应该对处于一个她从未见过的成年人的陌生环境中感到没问题。他们记录下来，他们告诉我，她有分离困难。
Whereas what I saw was very typical and it was all of a minute or two of our time, but that it was perceived as being inappropriate when I think if we understand child development and behavioral development and all of that, it wouldn't be unusual, but they've just decided on a fairly arbitrary basis that this is what they expect to see, whether we're talking about cognitively, pre-academics or developmentally. And then when we layer on racial bias and different types of biases on top of that, where there's inappropriate understandings of culpability for behavior or willfulness of behavior, that's when we see students being pushed out via suspension and expulsion,
然而我所看到的是非常典型的，而且这只是我们时间的一两分钟，但它被认为是不恰当的，而我认为如果我们理解儿童发展和行为发展以及所有这些，这并不罕见，但他们只是在一个相当随意的基础上决定了这就是他们期望看到的，无论我们是在谈论认知、学前学术还是发展方面。然后当我们在此之上叠加种族偏见和不同类型的偏见时，对行为的责任或行为的故意性存在不恰当的理解，这就是我们看到学生通过停学和开除被推出去的时候，
where instead, if we, again, we just applied what are some really well-known behavioral principles and strategies for responding to behavior or creating the behaviors we want. We wouldn't even have these problems in the first place. But again, I ask how often are those things taught in pre-service and in-service professional development? Yeah. And there's something called a kindergarten readiness assessment. And I've been in two state-level meetings where this kindergarten readiness assessment was leading to all types of consternation. Because they're testing this district and they're finding that, you know, something like,
而相反，如果我们，再次，我们只是应用了一些非常著名的行为原则和策略来应对行为或创造我们想要的行为。我们甚至根本不会有这些问题。但再次，我问这些东西在职前和在职专业发展中被教授的频率是多少？是的。有一种东西叫做“幼儿园准备评估”。我参加过两次州级会议，这次幼儿园准备评估导致了各种各样的惊慌。因为他们正在测试这个学区，他们发现，你知道，大约，
50% of their students was kindergarten ready. And when I would ask basic questions about, you know, what is the test measuring? How long has the test been out? Is there any district out there where the majority of their students are kindergarten ready? And the last state that I looked at, more white students were kindergarten ready than Asian students. But yet when you looked at their later achievement rates, the Asian students were doing better. So what kind of long-term predictions are we making when the racial results don't even comport with what we see? And it was difficult for them to answer these questions.
50%的学生准备好了上幼儿园。当我问一些基本问题时，关于，你知道，这个测试在测量什么？这个测试出来多久了？有没有哪个学区大多数学生都准备好上幼儿园了？我看的最后一个州，更多的白人学生比亚裔学生准备好上幼儿园。但当你观察他们后来的成就率时，亚裔学生表现得更好。那么，当种族结果甚至与我们所看到的不符时，我们正在做出什么样的长期预测？他们很难回答这些问题。
But that just goes to show how someone can put a test out there. Use that test to create a problem. And you have policymakers scrambling around trying to figure out why their kindergartners aren't ready. When again, just basic neuroscience tells us that their brains are still developing. And if they're not ready before five years old, that in no way means that they haven't learned what they need to learn during that time. And it's not even really about learning at that point. It's about experiences. You know, it's about, you know, being a child and experimenting with different things.
但这恰恰表明某人是如何发布一个测试的。利用那个测试来制造一个问题。而你有政策制定者忙乱地试图弄清楚为什么他们的幼儿园孩子没有准备好。当再次，基本的神经科学告诉我们，他们的大脑仍在发育。如果他们在五岁之前没有准备好，那绝不意味着他们在那段时间里没有学到他们需要学的东西。而且在那一点上，这甚至不是关于学习。这是关于经历。你知道，这是关于，你知道，作为一个孩子并尝试不同的东西。
but I think, you know, things like that. And there's also issues, you know, with a spike in psychotropic medications being prescribed to preschoolers. Somebody told me about that and I didn't even believe it. And off-label use. So it's not even what they're supposed to. It's just like, let's give them this cocktail and see what happens. What kind of drugs are those? Antipsychotics.
但我认为，你知道，像那样的事情。而且还有问题，你知道，给学前班学生开精神药物的激增。有人告诉我这件事，我甚至都不相信。还有超说明书用药。所以这甚至不是他们应该做的。这就像，让我们给他们这种鸡尾酒疗法，看看会发生什么。那是什么样的药？抗精神病药。
Yeah, I think antipsychotics is the most common one. Stimulants. Yeah. Yeah. So you want to, so a four-year-old who can't sit still in school, which is oftentimes very developmentally appropriate. But it's perceived as a problem because there's this standard that people forget that they just made those up, right? And oftentimes they're completely divorced from the research and all the theory around, again, human development. And then when kids can't follow the standards, it's quick to give a pill versus to teach the adults, whether we're talking. talking about parents, teachers, administrators, how to support positive behavior. And so it happens a lot
是的，我认为抗精神病药是最常见的一种。兴奋剂。是的。是的。所以你想，所以一个在学校坐不住的四岁孩子，这通常是非常符合发展规律的。但它被视为一个问题，因为有这样一个标准，人们忘记了他们只是编造了这些，对吧？而且它们通常与研究以及围绕人类发展的理论完全脱节。然后当孩子们不能遵循这些标准时，给一颗药丸比教成年人——无论我们是在谈论父母、老师、行政人员——如何支持积极行为要快得多。所以这种情况经常发生
and who does it happen to more, kids with disabilities, kids from low income backgrounds, because it's cheaper on the health services side of things to prescribe than to engage in family therapy or to send out a behavioral specialist to help build the parents' competency to deal with behavior. we see like really high rates of this off-label prescription with kids in foster care, for instance, who, again, their behaviors, if we think again from what we know in psychology and what we know about principles of behavior, a lot of what we see is very expected, given the unpredictability of their settings or the trauma they've experienced. But instead of applying the psychological treatments we know are effective, the quickest way to do it is to give them this kind of prescription cocktail
而且这种情况发生在谁身上更多，残疾儿童，来自低收入背景的孩子，因为在医疗服务方面，开处方比进行家庭治疗或派遣行为专家来帮助建立父母处理行为的能力更便宜。我们看到这种超说明书处方在寄养儿童中比例非常高，例如，他们，再次，如果我们从我们所知道的心理学和我们所知道的行为原则来思考，我们所看到的很多东西是非常预期的，考虑到他们环境的不可预测性或他们所经历的创伤。但与其应用我们知道有效的心理治疗，最快的方法是给他们这种处方鸡尾酒
that then is going to have a whole host of science. side effects and unwanted side effects, but it's much more common than it should be. And what are the consequences of this exclusionary discipline in terms of academic achievement and future success? Well, there's, as far as I know, there's no research to support its use in terms of reducing the likelihood of whatever the behavior was that it was applied for or in producing desired behaviors. But we do have a lot of research to show that it can undermine students' academic achievement, students who are suspended and expelled are more likely to be retained, to drop out
然后这会有一系列副作用和不想要的副作用，但这比它应该的要常见得多。这种排斥性纪律在学业成就和未来成功方面的后果是什么？嗯，据我所知，没有任何研究支持其在减少应用该行为的可能性或产生期望行为方面的使用。但我们确实有很多研究表明，它会损害学生的学业成就，被停学和开除的学生更有可能留级、辍学
of school, to be involved in criminal justice. So we have a lot of research to suggest the negative effects that it has and very little to indicate any positive effects. There's research that also shows that it disconnects them from their school and that other teachers tend to treat them bad, even if the problem. wasn't in their class. So there's a ripple effect for them. When they come back from suspension, they're already behind in their classes, but they also have the stigma of being suspended, which is also problematic. It's this interesting dynamic that we put some, we put a lot of emphasis in promoting attendance and in fighting truancy because we know that keeping kids in school and
，卷入刑事司法。所以我们有很多研究表明它产生的负面影响，而几乎没有迹象表明有任何积极影响。有研究还表明，它使他们与学校脱节，其他老师往往对他们不好，即使问题不在他们的班级。所以这对他们有连锁反应。当他们从停学中回来时，他们在班级里已经落后了，但他们还带有被停学的污名，这也是有问题的。这是一个有趣的动态，我们把一些，我们非常强调促进出勤和打击逃学，因为我们知道让孩子留在学校和
really strong attendance is important. And yet then when students are suspended, expelled, even in school suspension where they're missing that instruction. It accumulates or it amounts to a lot of misinstruction over time. And so then it's not really surprising then if people are failing classes being held back, not wanting to be at school because they're missing out. It may just be a few hours or a few days here and there, but it's not as if there are opportunities built in to make up that time. So they're just losing it and the kids who get exposed to it more and more then are disengaging and are more likely to leave school entirely. And again, it's a fair predictable consequence of an inappropriate practice.
非常强的出勤率很重要。然而，当学生被停学、开除，甚至是在校停学，他们错过了教学。随着时间的推移，它积累或相当于大量的教学缺失。所以如果人们挂科、留级、不想在学校，因为他们错过了，那也就不足为奇了。可能只是这里那里几个小时或几天，但并不是说有内置的机会来弥补那些时间。所以他们只是失去了它，而那些越来越多地接触到它的孩子随后正在脱离，更有可能完全离开学校。而且再次，这是不当做法的一个相当可预测的后果。
How does this all relate to the school to prison pipeline? Are students who are suspended or expelled or expelled more likely to end up in the criminal justice system? Yes. And there's plenty of research to support that, especially when schools are using law enforcement, referring to law enforcement, particularly for those non-dangerous offenses. So what is the status of mental health services offered in K-12 schools? I mean, we've talked a lot about teacher training.
这一切与学校到监狱的管道有什么关系？被停学或开除的学生更有可能进入刑事司法系统吗？是的。而且有大量的研究支持这一点，特别是当学校使用执法部门、转介给执法部门时，特别是针对那些非危险的违法行为。那么K-12学校提供的心理健康服务的现状如何？我的意思是，我们谈了很多关于教师培训的内容。
that can help, but in terms of what is being offered to help students who have mental health challenges that they're facing? Well, there's a survey called Health Behaviors on School Age Children, and they surveyed various schools about the services that's available. And one of the things you see in that survey is that when it comes to, if someone were asked, do you have mental health services at the school? is nearly a 100% response rate of affirmative. But then when you get into specific things like family,
这可以有所帮助，但就为面临心理健康挑战的学生提供什么帮助而言？嗯，有一个调查叫做“学龄儿童健康行为”，他们调查了各个学校关于可用的服务。你在那个调查中看到的一件事是，当涉及到，如果有人被问到，你在学校有心理健康服务吗？几乎是100%的肯定回答率。但当你进入具体的事情，比如家庭，
especially drugs, you know, there's very few schools that have anything related to drug use, you know, to deal with that. And, you know, there's students who, I've heard of one student who got a 10-day suspension because they smoke the cigarette. But yet there's nobody there that, really talk to them about, you know, putting chemicals in your body at a younger age.
特别是毒品，你知道，很少有学校有任何与吸毒相关的东西，你知道，来处理这个问题。而且，你知道，有学生，我听说过一个学生因为抽烟被停学10天。但却没有人真正和他们谈论，你知道，在年轻时把化学物质放进你的身体里。
So I think that's the state of it. There's schools that believe they have mental health. But when you really open up the hood, they have it a name only. And so in order for us to really get them the services that they need, there needs to be a look at what people think they have in terms of mental health. and really get into these specific issues that certain students might be dealing with and make sure that they can name all of those issues and services that are available for students to work on.
所以我认为这就是它的状态。有些学校认为他们有心理健康服务。但当你真正打开引擎盖时，他们只是有名无实。所以为了让我们真正让他们得到他们需要的服务，需要看看人们认为他们在心理健康方面拥有什么，并真正进入某些学生可能正在处理的这些具体问题，并确保他们能够命名所有这些问题以及可供学生使用的服务。
Yeah, many schools are under-resourced on this. And so, for instance, the ACLU recently did an analysis of data submitted to the Office of Civil Rights under the Department of Education, and they identified some pretty substantial lack of, of school psychologist services, school counselor services, social worker services, so schools where none was reported. But then we also see even where schools say they have mental health services,
是的，许多学校在这方面资源不足。所以，例如，美国公民自由联盟最近对提交给教育部民权办公室的数据进行了分析，他们发现了一些相当严重的学校心理学家服务、学校辅导员服务、社会工作者服务的缺乏，所以有些学校报告说根本没有。但我们也看到，即使在学校说他们有心理健康服务的地方，
oftentimes it can be an itinerant psychologist who's serving multiple school buildings so that they might be in a building for half a day a week or one day a week. And the bandwidth for somebody like that is really limited. We also see many, many settings are far beyond the recommended ratio of student to provider when we look across different mental health providers.
通常它可能是一位巡回心理学家，服务于多个校舍，所以他们可能一周在某个校舍待半天或一天。而像那样的人的带宽真的很有限。当我们观察不同的心理健康提供者时，我们还看到许多、许多设置远远超出了建议的学生与提供者的比例。
And so they may be there, but if you have one person in a half a day a week that's supposed to serve thousands of kids and families, that's just an impossible situation they've been put in. And so then it's no surprise that they can't leverage the expertise they bring to affect positive outcomes. And so I think not just making sure that they're there at all, but thinking about ratios, thinking about the composition of those mental health support. So it's not enough to just have a,
所以他们可能在那里，但如果你有一个人一周半天，应该服务成千上万的孩子和家庭，那只是他们被置于的一个不可能的境地。所以难怪他们无法利用他们带来的专业知识来产生积极的结果。所以我认为不仅仅是确保他们根本在那里，而是考虑比例，考虑这些心理健康支持的构成。所以仅仅有一个，
with an external provider for four hours a week services, which is another fairly common arrangement that we see. But we have to invest in having people who are actually there to serve the families and then can do so in a reasonable manner. I want to turn now to some of those policy issues. We've been touching on a little bit throughout the show. In December 2018, the Federal Commission on School Safety recommended rescinding Obama-era guidance intended to reduce discrimination in school discipline. The Department of Education promptly implemented this recommendation. So what will be the impact of this action? I'm not sure. The guidance documents, I think, was an important tool for people who wanted to do something
与外部提供者每周四小时的服务是不够的，这是我们看到的另一种相当常见的安排。但我们必须投资于拥有真正服务家庭的人员，然后能够以合理的方式这样做。我现在想转向那些政策问题。我们在整个节目中一直在触及一点。2018年12月，联邦学校安全委员会建议废除旨在减少学校纪律歧视的奥巴马时代的指导方针。教育部迅速实施了这一建议。那么这一行动的影响将是什么？我不确定。我认为指导文件是那些想要做点什么的人的重要工具
about it. But people who were not interested in changing what they were doing, the guidance document didn't necessarily mandate them to do anything. It did point to the laws of the particular state and it was able to show certain people that what they were doing was outside of the outside of the legal boundaries in their state, but the state still have those laws. And so what a person was doing under the the guidance documents, they still should be doing because that's the laws of their state. So I think that while the guidance documents was important information, it helped people who wanted to do something more and people who didn't care about doing anything, I think they
关于它。但那些对改变他们正在做的事情不感兴趣的人，指导文件并不一定强制他们做任何事情。它确实指出了特定州的法律，并且能够向某些人表明他们正在做的事情超出了他们州的法律界限，但该州仍然有那些法律。所以一个人在指导文件下正在做的事情，他们仍然应该做，因为那是他们州的法律。所以我认为，虽然指导文件是重要的信息，它帮助了那些想要做更多事情的人，而那些不在乎做任何事情的人，我认为他们
continue to do what they were doing. So there's nothing firm putting it in place saying that you must do this, which is guidelines for schools too? Yeah. Now, on the contrary, something else that happened during Obama years is there was a lot more federal enforcement of where the exclusionary practices was such that the lawyers within the Office of Civil Rights was able to actually bring. a case against those. And so you saw more of that happening during the Obama years.
继续做他们正在做的事情。所以没有什么坚定的东西把它放在那里说你必须这样做，这也是学校的指导方针？是的。现在，相反，奥巴马时期发生的另一件事是，联邦对排斥性做法的执法力度要大得多，以至于民权办公室内的律师能够真正提起诉讼。所以你在奥巴马时期看到了更多这种情况的发生。
But still those, the scope of them, you know, the number of districts that were being targeted by the Obama administration, you know, where they, that was acting in the enforcement was still too small to actually put a dent in the larger problem. Yeah. I mean, I think those changes in how investigations happen are going to be really important because previously a complaint by a single family about a single student would trigger investigation for the entire setting or system. And now what we're going to see is it's going to stop at that student. And so in a lot of those instances, when these investigations happened, when they actually went into the records and looked at, so it's not uncommon, for instance,
但仍然是那些，它们的范围，你知道，被奥巴马政府针对的学区数量，你知道，他们在执法中采取行动的地方，仍然太小，无法真正对更大的问题产生影响。是的。我的意思是，我认为调查方式的改变将非常重要，因为以前，单个家庭对单个学生的投诉会触发对整个设置或系统的调查。而现在我们将看到的是，它将停留在那个学生身上。所以，在很多这样的情况下，当这些调查发生时，当他们真正进入记录并查看时，所以，例如，并不罕见，
to find that on paper, schools have appropriate policies in place. But then when they look at implementation of those policies, they could find different implementation depending on who the student was. And so I just did an analysis with a student who also was a lawyer. And we actually looked at for special education disproportionality, what happened in those investigations of what came out of them. And so again, it's not uncommon for these facially neutral, non-discriminatory policies to be in place.
发现纸面上，学校有适当的政策。但当他们查看这些政策的实施时，他们可能会根据学生的不同发现不同的实施情况。所以我刚刚和一个也是律师的学生做了一个分析。我们实际上查看了特殊教育的不成比例，在那些调查中发生了什么，结果是什么。所以再次，这些表面上中立、非歧视性的政策存在并不罕见。
But then what happens in the classroom, what happens in the principal's office or the assistant principal's office was different if it was a black student. or an English language learner than if it was a white student or a white girl in particular. And so that became an really important lever for requiring, oftentimes the investigations resulted in memoranda that required ongoing training and monitoring of what was going on, explicit policies, evaluation to not just check and make sure that policies and procedures were appropriately formulated, but also that they were being implemented fairly and so that all kids were being treated, equally. And we're not going to see that happening anymore because the Department of Ed
但随后在课堂上发生的事情，在校长办公室或副校长办公室发生的事情，如果是黑人学生或英语学习者，与如果是白人学生或特别是白人女孩，是不同的。所以这成为了一个非常重要的杠杆，要求，调查往往导致了备忘录，要求持续的培训和对正在发生的事情的监控，明确的政策，评估不仅要检查并确保政策和程序制定得当，而且还要确保它们被公平地实施，以便所有孩子都被平等对待。而我们不会再看到这种情况发生了，因为教育部
under Bretzi DeVos has said that those kind of systemic investigations aren't necessary. And so I think that was really important for families and communities to have that card to play, so to speak. And now that's going away. And so if it's not in the students file, they're not going to, that individual students file absent, say, a whole group of families banding together to file the complaint, we're just not going to see. those types of investigations or resolutions coming out of them anymore. What recommendations do you both have for federal policymakers to address exclusionary discipline?
在贝特西·德沃斯（Betsy DeVos）领导下说，那种系统性的调查是不必要的。所以我认为这对家庭和社区来说，拥有那张牌是非常重要的。而现在那正在消失。所以如果它不在学生档案中，他们不会，那个个别学生的档案，除非，比如说，一大群家庭联合起来提出投诉，我们只是不会再看到那些类型的调查或从中产生的决议。你们两位对联邦政策制定者解决排斥性纪律有什么建议？
I mean, I think investing first and foremost in capacity building from investment, so sustained investment in pre-service and in-service training, graduate training for mental health providers because most of them have to have, most school-based providers have to have either a master's degree or doctoral degree to qualify for state certificates to be like a school psychologist or a school counselor. And we know from surveys of graduates that many times they're carrying six-figure debt. And there's programs that exist, particularly within different dimensions of federal policy. For instance, like IDEA Part D supports graduate preparation for related service providers for kids with disabilities.
我的意思是，我认为首先要投资于能力建设，从投资开始，即对职前和在职培训、心理健康提供者的研究生培训进行持续投资，因为他们中的大多数人必须，大多数基于学校的提供者必须拥有硕士学位或博士学位，才有资格获得州证书，成为学校心理学家或学校辅导员。而且我们从毕业生的调查中知道，很多时候他们背负着六位数的债务。而且存在一些项目，特别是在联邦政策的不同维度内。例如，像IDEA D部分支持为残疾儿童的相关服务提供者进行研究生准备。
And so maintaining those kind of investments become really important. and just investing in things that work. So investing in programs that will support positive mental health outcomes, positive behavioral outcomes, research-based social-emotional supports. So a few things before we wrap up. What can parents do with the information we've talked about today? I admittedly have difficulty responding to what can parents do because sometimes I believe that I'm mostly talking to parents with social capital.
所以维持这些投资变得非常重要。并且只是投资于有效的事情。所以投资于将支持积极心理健康结果、积极行为结果、基于研究的社会情感支持的项目。所以，在我们结束之前，还有几件事。家长们可以利用我们今天谈到的信息做什么？我承认在回答家长们可以做什么时有困难，因为有时我相信我主要是在和有社会资本的家长交谈。
when I respond to questions like this. And I think, you know, most parents, they want what's in the best interest of their children. But the way that the system is set up now, a parent who is college educated, a parent who has certain resources, a parent who knows how to express themselves in a way that we learn to express ourselves when we go through formal education, they have the edge and that's the reality. So the parents who have that social capital, what I would implore us to do is to look out for parents who don't. Parents who are working a wage job,
当我回答这样的问题时。而且我认为，你知道，大多数家长，他们想要对他们的孩子最有利的事情。但按照系统现在的设置方式，一个受过大学教育的家长，一个拥有某些资源的家长，一个知道如何以我们通过正规教育学习表达自己的方式来表达自己的家长，他们有优势，这就是现实。所以那些拥有社会资本的家长，我恳求我们做的是，去照顾那些没有社会资本的家长。那些从事工资工作的家长，
parents who take public transportation to get their child to school, and who may more often be late because of unreliable public transportation, who have to actually. lose money if they were to take off work to go to a PTA meeting or to go to a parent teacher conference. So we need to look out for those parents. And I think that, you know, the people who are working in this space, the advocates and the researchers like us, we need to do a better job of joining forces with other parents and speaking for them and so. schools need to do a better job of reaching parents that are not college educated and that are
那些乘坐公共交通工具送孩子上学的家长，他们可能因为不可靠的公共交通而更经常迟到，他们如果请假去参加家长会或去参加家长教师会议，实际上必须损失金钱。所以我们需要照顾那些家长。而且我认为，你知道，在这个领域工作的人，像我们这样的倡导者和研究人员，我们需要做得更好，与其他家长联合起来，为他们说话，所以。学校需要做得更好，去接触那些没有受过大学教育和是工人阶级的家长。
working class. So I know that doesn't necessarily answer the question of what parents should do, but I'm thinking more about the mentality that we should have as parents when we try to work together to resolve this issue. I think knowing their rights can be really important. And that's hard to do because even as I interact with my daughter's school, I realize how knowing what I know, it's still incredibly cumbersome and things are so complicated. But I think to the extent that parents can find and access those resources that have been developed for them through a variety of different technical assistance mechanisms that are out there. So for parents with disabilities in particular, there's a whole host of federally funded centers that have developed guidance,
所以我知道这不一定回答了家长应该做什么的问题，但我更多地是在思考当我们试图共同努力解决这个问题时，我们作为家长应该有的心态。我认为了解他们的权利真的非常重要。而且这很难做到，因为即使我与我女儿的学校互动，我也意识到知道我所知道的东西，它仍然极其繁琐，事情太复杂了。但我认为，在家长能够找到并获取那些通过各种不同的技术援助机制为他们开发的资源的情况下。所以特别是对于残疾学生的家长，有一大批联邦资助的中心，它们已经开发了指导，
materials specifically for families, but also for teachers in school districts. There are equity assistance centers, and I'm affiliated for the one in my region, that they're primarily there as a proactive resource for schools that are going to get themselves as a way to avoid investigations with the Office of Civil Rights, but a lot of them also develop information for families about what their rights are. Westlaw is a nice resource for families, but I think just frankly, you can Google a lot of this stuff. Like, what should I do if my student is expelled? What are my rights if my student is suspended? Because a lot of it's about knowing the right questions to ask. And even then, they can still encounter a lot of difficulty,
专门针对家庭的材料，但也针对学区的教师。有公平援助中心，我隶属于我所在地区的那个，它们主要是作为学校的主动资源，以避免与民权办公室的调查，但它们中的许多也为家庭开发了关于他们的权利是什么的信息。Westlaw是家庭的一个很好的资源，但我认为坦率地说，你可以谷歌搜索很多这些东西。比如，如果我的学生被开除，我该怎么办？如果我的学生被停学，我的权利是什么？因为很多时候是关于知道要问正确的问题。即使那样，他们仍然可能遇到很多困难，
but the first step is just knowing how to advocate effectively. And luckily, there's a variety of information online to help with that. And what about individual school districts and teachers? Is there are other things they can take away from what we've talked about today and see if they can improve these disparities in them in their schools? Yeah, teachers need to communicate with their students and their families a lot more. A lot of times the problematic behavior that they are confronted with, they'd understand it better if they just talk to them and they would contextualize it better. I remember asking a group of teachers, I said, how do you feel about students who doze
但第一步是了解如何有效地进行倡导。幸运的是，网上有各种各样的信息可以提供帮助。那么个别学区和教师呢？他们能从我们今天讨论的内容中汲取什么，看看能否改善学校内部的这些差异吗？是的，教师需要与学生及其家庭进行更多的沟通。很多时候，他们所面对的问题行为，如果他们能与学生沟通，就能更好地理解并将其置于具体情境中。我记得曾问过一群老师，我说，你们对在课堂上打瞌睡的学生有什么感觉？
off in your class. And all of them, you know, they didn't like it. They thought it was disrespectful and they used that terminology. I said, well, what if you talk to the student and you found out that they were dozing off because they, their parent had a significant other in the house, had a boyfriend or girlfriend in the house that they were afraid of and they saw them looking at them a certain way and they were afraid that that person was going to sneak into their bed. How did you feel about them dozing off? And then they all immediately became very sympathetic. But the reality is that a lot of times when you see things like dozing off are even, you know, disrespect, oppositional behavior, a lot of times it comes from a place that we might understand
他们都不喜欢这样。他们认为这是不尊重的，并使用了这个术语。我说，如果你们和学生谈过，发现他们打瞌睡是因为家里有亲戚，比如家里有男朋友或女朋友，他们感到害怕，看到那个人盯着他们看，担心那个人会溜进他们的床，你们对他们打瞌睡又有什么感觉呢？然后他们立刻变得非常同情。但现实是，很多时候当你看到打瞌睡甚至是不尊重、对抗行为时，很多时候它源于我们可能理解的地方，
if we just got the details. But you have to care enough to get those details. So I would say opened up the communication and, you know, just, just understand. Teachers can also, you know, take their professional development very seriously and understand that, you know, I know that they have options on what they could, you know, do in their PD. You know, they can, you know, learn about this new way to teach math, or they could learn about how to develop empathy, our cultural competence and things like that. But, you know, they've, in their schooling, they've learned about, you know, all the things that they need to learn about. But professional development is the one opportunity they really have to really get into these issues. And, you know, I'll talk about
如果我们能了解细节的话。但你必须足够关心才能获得这些细节。所以我建议敞开沟通，去理解。教师也可以非常认真地对待他们的专业发展，并明白他们有选择权。他们可以学习这种新的数学教学方法，或者学习如何培养同理心、文化能力等。但在他们的学校教育中，他们已经学习了所有需要学习的东西。但专业发展是他们真正深入探讨这些问题的唯一机会。我会谈谈
my own frustration as someone who does professional development is going into a district where I know that the teaching force is only about 20 percent. people of color, but yet in the 200 people who signed up from my workshop, it's about 70% people of color. And that happens a lot. So a lot of times the people that really need this information the most are not the people that's getting it. And even the white teachers who will be in the professional development, just the questions that they ask, a lot of times I can tell that they have learned, And they at least have a base knowledge of this. But there are too many educators out there who don't really see this as their issue.
我作为一名从事专业发展工作的人的挫败感，我走进一个学区，我知道那里的教师队伍中只有约20%是有色人种，但在报名参加我研讨会的200人中，约有70%是有色人种。这种情况经常发生。所以很多时候，最需要这些信息的人反而没有得到。即使是参加专业发展的白人教师，从他们提出的问题来看，很多时候我能看出他们已经学过，至少有这方面的基础知识。但仍有太多的教育工作者并不真正认为这是他们的问题。
And so they need to take that more seriously. Yeah, I think to the extent people can invest that time and energy into unlearning biases and learning cultural responsive, non-discriminatory practices. Also investing time in developing behavior management skills. So this might be through individual or classroom level positive behavior interventions of supports are ideally a school-wide, a PBIS system. There are also a variety of strategies and programs available to support positive student-teacher relationships, which again, the research shows that can reduce some of these behavioral
所以他们需要更认真地对待这一点。是的，我认为人们可以在多大程度上投入时间和精力去消除偏见，学习文化响应式、非歧视性的实践。同时投入时间发展行为管理技能。这可以通过个人或课堂层面的积极行为干预与支持，或者理想情况下是全校范围的PBIS系统来实现。还有各种策略和项目可用于支持积极的师生关系，研究表明这可以减少其中一些行为
challenges, also either at the classroom level or the school-wide level investing in ways to improve school climate. So again, there's programs strategies that are there. They don't have to constantly be reinventing the wheel, but rather taking advantage of the knowledge and resources that are already out there. Is there anything a general listener can do, can take action on? Yeah, I mean, different people are at different places in this issue. You know, some of the listeners, they may have their own children in schools that have these issues.
挑战，也可以在课堂层面或全校层面投资改善学校氛围。同样，有现成的项目和策略。他们不必不断地重新发明轮子，而是利用现有的知识和资源。普通听众能做些什么，能采取什么行动吗？是的，不同的人在这个问题上处于不同的位置。有些听众可能他们的孩子所在的学校就存在这些问题。
So there are certain things that they could do. But, you know, just a general public, we can use more people speaking out against certain things. And, you know, there's a lot of times I'll see articles about, you know, suspensions are, you know, things that happen, you know, like in, like what happened in, in Montgomery County schools recently where someone, a student had to talk to police officers because he bought toy money to school and somebody said that it might be counterfeit. But a lot of times on these message boards, you'll see people who have just really baked into this idea of, well, you know, students are out of control. We need to get them.
所以他们可以做一些特定的事情。但对于普通大众来说，我们需要更多人站出来反对某些事情。很多时候，我会看到关于停学或类似事件的文章，比如最近蒙哥马利县学校发生的事情，一名学生不得不与警察交谈，因为他带了玩具钱到学校，有人说可能是假币。但在这些留言板上，你会看到很多人已经根深蒂固地认为，学生们失控了，我们需要让他们
in line and all this kind of stuff. And a lot of, you know, there's this saying, you know, the empty wagons are usually the loudest, or empty wagons are the loudest, or shallow creeks are the most noisy. And a lot of times with the general public, I see people who talk the most, have the most ignorant things to say about the topic. So I know that people who listen to this podcast are very smart. They are not the empty wagons or shallow creek, but people who, really can get into this issue.
守规矩之类的。有句俗话说，空车最响，或者浅溪最吵。很多时候，在普通大众中，我看到那些说得最多的人，对这个话题的看法最无知。所以我知道听这个播客的人都很聪明。他们不是空车或浅溪，而是真正能深入探讨这个问题的人。
So we need them on message boards and we need them talking out when they have an opportunity. We need them to be the counterbalance to this issue so that more people are aware. This is one of those examples where that notion of giving psychology away,
所以我们需要他们在留言板上发言，我们需要他们在有机会时大声疾呼。我们需要他们成为这个问题的制衡力量，让更多人意识到这一点。这是一个“传播心理学”概念的例子，
I think psychology has a lot to bring to bear about how we can do this better so that we see better outcomes with students and so to the extent that everybody's, feels empowered to speak up. So it's not just those empty ways. wagons dominating the conversations, but just reminding people that, again, we know how to respond to this well, right? So let's do that. And we're probably going to have to advocate for it a lot
我认为心理学在如何做得更好方面有很多贡献，这样我们就能看到学生更好的成果，因此，如果每个人都感到有权发言，那么不仅仅是那些“空车”主导对话，而是提醒人们，我们知道如何很好地应对这一点，对吧？所以让我们这样做。我们可能需要为此进行大量的
and repeatedly. But I think there's a lot of potential for change. Because again, I mean, nobody, I suspect nobody goes into teaching or working in schools because they hate children, right? I hope people who are there are there if their belief in fostering the development of future generations as part of it. And so if we can link it back to that kind of fundamental ideal, hopefully we can affect change, but also just kind of give away psychology, because we know so much that can help to improve this. So let's help that to happen. Thank you so much for joining us, Dr. Sullivan and Dr. Toltsin. Obviously a lot of work to do in this area, but you left us on a hopeful note. So that can be done in psychology and psychologists can do a lot to address this issue.
且反复的倡导。但我认为变革潜力巨大。因为没有人是因为讨厌孩子才去教书或在学校工作的，对吧？我希望在那里的人是因为相信培养下一代。如果我们能将其与这种基本理想联系起来，希望我们能推动变革，同时也传播心理学，因为我们知道很多可以帮助改善这一点的方法。所以让我们促成这一点。非常感谢你们的加入，Sullivan博士和Toltsin博士。显然在这个领域还有很多工作要做，但你们给我们留下了一个充满希望的结尾。心理学可以做到这一点，心理学家可以在解决这个问题上发挥很大作用。
Thank you so much for your time. Thank you. Before we go, just a reminder that you can email us your comments and ideas to Speaking of Psychology at APA.org. Also, please consider giving us a rating in iTunes. We'd really appreciate it. Speaking of Psychology is part of the APA podcast network, which includes other great podcasts like APA journals dialogue about new psychological research and progress notes about the practice of psychology.
非常感谢你们的时间。谢谢。在结束之前，提醒大家可以通过电子邮件将评论和想法发送至Speaking of Psychology at APA.org。此外，请考虑在iTunes上给我们评分。我们将不胜感激。Speaking of Psychology是APA播客网络的一部分，该网络还包括其他很棒的播客，如APA期刊关于新心理学研究的对话，以及关于心理学实践的进展笔记。
You can find all of our podcasts on iTunes Stitcher or wherever you get your podcasts. You can also visit our website, speakingof psychology.org to listen to more episodes. I'm Caitlin Luna with the American Psychological Association. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
你可以在iTunes、Stitcher或任何你获取播客的地方找到我们所有的播客。你也可以访问我们的网站speakingofpsychology.org收听更多剧集。我是美国心理学会的Caitlin Luna。本集目前还没有评论。点击转录中的任何句子即可发表评论。